I can't say I'm the biggest Taylor Swift
fan in the world I'm not sure I've ever
intentionally listened to any of her
music but I gotta tell you on this
occasion I will let her finish because
my producers in their wisdom played me
one of her newest songs anti-hero I
actually think it's very very
conservative click the link in the
description below so you never miss out
on any of the fine content that comes
only for daily wire Plus members on our
member block it is like a whole other
YouTube channel just for you
I have this thing where I get older but
just never wiser Midnight's become my
afternoons
[Music]
and prices
[Music]
[Music]
I don't know that I've ever listened to
an entire Taylor Swift song to
completion this is really smart though
even that first line when she says I'm
getting older but never wiser and this
is a big problem and I'm depressed now
and I'm just up in the middle of the
night and I don't and you see the ghosts
everywhere right the ghosts are
representing
this kind of past that's gone away this
past that she had sort of made an idol
out of it when it was the present but
because she she never had any goal
toward which she was progressing because
she never had a Clear Vision of the
future that she wanted because she was
just content to just kind of be a big
lib and just live for herself and do the
shots and that that's all all that's fun
is just like right now because of that
she's super duper depressed and then all
those kind of fun moments in the present
when you're in your early 20s let's say
if you never mature if you never get any
wiser as you physically get older those
nice memories become kind of ghosts that
haunt you because they're the reminder
of better times at times that have left
you because you have to grow up
eventually if you just remain an
overgrown child you're going to be very
very miserable if you do the things that
are proper to a 22 year old when you're
52 they're no longer proper and they're
no longer going to be satisfying and so
then Taylor Swift says I've been
spending all of this time you know
focused on all these stupid things and I
haven't been looking in the mirror and
suggesting perhaps the problem is me
okay
[Music]
did you hear my covert narcissism like
disguise is altruism like some kind of
Consciousness was there whoa oh my gosh
did you hear my play that line again
[Music]
wow did you hear my covert narcissism
that I disguise as altruism oh my gosh
is Taylor just a far right conservative
because she's just absolutely cutting to
the heart of the the libs today which is
their their utter narcissism
and I mean that really in a very
technical sense that the libs who who
value nothing over over themselves who
don't worship God who don't you know see
their fellow human beings as creatures
made in the image and likeness of God
and therefore they're brothers and
sisters who they should have some care
for through charity they just basically
say well I want to be a good person
because I want to feel good and I want
and I just I feel bad and I want to feel
good and it's it's a kind of look at me
look at me you know I'm so wonderful
they're always the ones you know
launching the big very public non-profit
organizations throwing big big parties
for themselves they're doing it because
it's a covert narcissism that they mask
as an altruism when they post the black
Square on Instagram or when they they
always it's always slacktivism right
it's always on social media it's all
about them even she says earlier I've
been I've been pierced through the heart
but never killed which I assume is a
reference to
she's had all these boyfriends but none
of them have ever really taken her she's
never committed to any of them I don't
think Taylor Swift has ever been married
but she's almost saying I wish I had
been I wish I'd been pierced through the
heart and killed I wish I'd surrendered
my narcissistic self in love to another
human being but I haven't done any of
that because I'm just so damn
narcissistic
[Music]
you're drinking that wine in aging wine
Millennial lady
I'm the problem that's made well
[Music]
[Applause]
I have this
[Music]
dreams
from hell
what who got the beach house he's having
it turned into a [ __ ] cat sanctuary
that's not even like a bee there's
probably a secret encoded message that
means something else yeah PS there's no
secret encoded message that means
something else love Taylor great well
good job Chad you finally pushed it too
far what are you implying by that I
think she's implying that you haven't
hesitated to trade on mom's name okay
I'm just gonna say it I think she killed
her you've got
she didn't fall off the balcony she was
pushed
what's amazing is you're going to have
Libs who have no self-consciousness
whatsoever they're going to listen to
that it's kind of ironic oh yes I'm me
I'm the problem it's me no look at her
kids her kids are terrible look at this
and that no come on it's just ironic
you're not the problem Taylor be easier
on yourself but she is and she's looking
out from the the coffin and she see
these are her kids these are the people
that she formed that is a problem and
she has created problems and she's I I
think I read this as Earnest I read this
as sincerely introspective and really
insightful I don't know who wrote the
song If she wrote this this is
incredibly wow it's the most
conservative song I've heard in in years
oh my goodness so I have a one sheet
here about it and she says it's one of
her favorite songs she's ever written
was inspired by her insecurities and
feelings of self-hatred she has been
under Fire in the past few days because
critics have called one of her scenes
fat phobic oh that's funny because she's
looking down and seeing herself as fat
and you know you're not allowed to say
that if you're becoming unhealthy you
should try to do something to change
that people are going to say that the
song is ironic because you shouldn't
hate yourself no that's just a
perversion it's like a kind of an
anorexia because obviously Taylor Swift
is not fat so it's just a misperception
of herself and she's not really the
problem other people are the problem but
I much prefer the earnest read of the
song and I think the lyric the text the
lyrics really lend itself much more to
that which is no no she does have
problems that she has
made for herself or at the very least
exacerbated for herself and the solution
to that is not to think less of herself
exactly but rather to think of herself
less she has to take stock of herself
that's what the look and the mirror
thing is about but don't look in the
mirror merely to you know aggrandize
yourself or even to nitpick every little
problem and say I've got to fix that
wrinkle I've got to fix this I got to do
this but rather you look in the mirror
you take stock you say where am I right
now am I where I want to be why am I
waking up in the middle of the night why
am I getting older but not getting wiser
why is this stuff happening
it can't all just be a coincidence oh
maybe it's because I I've been pierced
through the heart but I've never given
myself over fully to another person I've
ever committed to this other person I've
never thought maybe I'm a little too
wrapped up in this problem or that
problem and this is an amazing song I
love this song in terms of the music
it's just a sort of fine pop whatever
but the lyrics really really good job
taylor if you want to see live reactions
weeks before anyone else click the link
in the description and join the Michael
Knowles show member block to get that
and so much more on daily wire plus
we'll see you there
[Music]